Republican lawmakers in Virginia say
Democrats are blocking a public hearing
into damaging allegations against the
state's lieutenant governor
Vanessa Tyson and Meredith Watson say
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax
sexually assaulted them and they are now
asking to testify in front of state
legislators Fairfax who is a Democrat is
categorically denied those allegations
Jeff Pegues is outside the state capitol
in Richmond where lawmakers are back for
the first time since February Jeff it
will be interesting to see if they take
up this conversation good morning to you
well I'm sure they will at least the
Republicans will because so far there is
no agreement in place for this public
hearing to happen even though
Republicans in the state legislature
have been pushing for it for weeks what
they want is for the lieutenant governor
and his accusers to testify this is a
proposal that the Republicans have been
pushing and they it would work by the
lieutenant governor and his accusers
being invited to testify during a
two-day hearing in either June or August
they would present their evidence before
a special bipartisan subcommittee
Virginia's house Democratic caucus
agrees that Fairfax should resign but
they say the investigation should be
handled by law enforcement they call
this proposal for a public hearing quote
politically motivated and an
unprecedented spectacle it is worth
noting that all the seats are up for
grabs and the virginia legislature and
this year's election and democrats of
course want to make gains on the
Republican held majority and there is
pressure on lawmakers here to act after
Vanessa Tyson and Meredith Watson came
forward with their allegations against
Fairfax in February they recently of
course spoke to Gayle King and
interviews that aired this week Fairfax
though says that both encounters with
Tyson and Watson were consensual he is
not under criminal investigation nor has
he expressed a desire to resign so
that's where this case stands right now
top state lawmakers who are Republicans
will be having a press conference later
on this morning and of course we will be
there john hf the gaze forest in
richmond thank you Jeff